[Music]
in penis parasite news whoa no no I know
you guys are getting upset right now
submitted by sip secret menu oh yeah a
man nearly died after a parasite crawled
into his penis and laid eggs oh my Jesus
Christ did he keep his dick it went into
the penis and laid eggs oh no [ __ ]
parasite was it I don't know the
parasite but it must have been one that
was not very good it was you know
pregnant you're not some people are like
I'm so unlucky I'm like lucky that dick
has a dick on a dick I hope that's what
the dick why do parasites have to look
like that like how could they can't look
cool parasites think you look like [ __ ]
too cuz they're [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they need to look like [ __ ] I need a
me I'm here a night
how did the thing get in his dish so
smile dude water probably you're so
smile but it looks like it can get in
there Joe that you would catch how does
a parasite get pregnant though bigger
[ __ ] itself can it there's some things
that got bigger goes to college and make
some mistakes that it's not very happy
with your wife's book itself yeah yeah
what a worm College and they get dry and
then it happens dammit
a worm never has to give consent really
why not has to give consent to the other
end oh I didn't think of that good point
I gotta get more local lizards like
leave some here they're like I'm gonna
leave this here then they come and they
and that's what they get pregnant they
don't have this sad way to [ __ ] like the
turtles oh yeah let me just come on your
eggs don't tunnels like a fish do that's
a fish is just like and then another
fish goes not shoot the cub and then
they just what they just go away
frogs are like that you'd have the best
science possible at home yeah I should
teach science
you should I won't go to this class yeah
how frogs [ __ ] alright there's a frog
right here with the [ __ ] a another
[ __ ] frog [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of those
eggs they don't get nobody [ __ ] the eggs
oh just come on it's Jessica
yeah so how come I need to learn about
this [ __ ] my dad says that yeah I don't
need to learn any of it so when you're
in the [ __ ] forest and you watch a
frog [ __ ] you know where the [ __ ] that
frog came from okay thanks
my dad thinks that you're you that
you're a failure your dad can suck a fat
dick Oh Oh mr. Jitsu Kawa yeah why does
shoot my dad stuck on a dick code so I
could tell him and that's where babies
come from that's where babies swallered
code this story here this British man
nearly died after this parasite crawled
up the penis laid some eggs in his body
so the way he got it was that he went
for a swim in Lake Malawi that's Joe
Andales Africa yeah let's just go jump
in this water so he was uh he had the
holiday of a lifetime with his friends
sounds like me I went and all I came
back with was the pic and the only thing
that touched my dick was a parasite dude
do you think that he's on a date with a
girl like five years from now anything
actually has a girlfriend and it gets
pretty sad so let me tell you he [ __ ]
her and then her bagina gets the best
sight cuz if you come it shoots it out
it wasn't even common which is parasites
he busted it made my skin crawl
mammoths camp I don't think this
parasite will work on me because I'm not
circumcised so when I go in cold water
I have an extra cloak that's what it's
for it's protected so I think I'll be
really hard for anybody to get in my
dick almost like goes inverted when I'm
cold I think that's what a for for skin
for skin was for yeah foreskin was for
that yeah but I feel like your dick
shivers and Bart stick looks really
relaxed I don't think I wasn't supposed
to envision my husband saying I feel
like I feel when you said the cloak I
just thought some Harry Potter [ __ ] and
it just disappeared well have you ever
been sick on a rainy day with the covers
that's what it looks I thought it'd go
like this in the clip you've never seen
an uncircumcised dick I mean but not
shriveled up and played out in that
scenario
really yes women I'm not in Coldwater
I'm like hey boys you digging
circumcised let me see that [ __ ] it's an
interesting science experiments very
interesting cuz I myself surprised
myself it turns into a big time cuz it's
not every day that I go into ice-cold
water and then I am in there for an hour
and I get out and I'm alive oh my god
it's like it's like a sea creature what
something is just literally just like
the skin like you're just like where did
your dick go I mean inside before but it
was more like I wasn't trying to
envision you oh okay now it's personal
hi welcome you just told me the whole
display of what your penis looks like
I'm sorry that was rude but you made eye
contact with me the whole time like yeah
this is the same thing now you can pick
them out in the lineup back there but
you don't know my skin color so it turns
purple in the cold I only saw it covered
in milk kinda what girls are my balls
coward himself and sriracha and he was
like dipping them in milk to get rid of
the burning JK party you thought I was
walking by oh he was showing everybody I
was just showing you I thought it's so
funny to see my balls they've been a
milk and it burned are you really
surprised that any of us saw that given
how often this guy's naked so long and
I've luckily never say that's the
surprising part I seen his dick look
away immediately I don't try to go
anyway so this story here this to 32
year old man so his name is James he
said that like I said he was swimming in
this lake and then when he came back
home that that's when he started
experiencing symptoms a couple months
after he already went home so he started
losing feeling in both legs and so he's
a cyclist so he thought anyone his
hobbies too sore yeah so then but then
his symptoms worsened and then he found
himself struggling even just walking up
a flight of stairs so he went to the
hospital and they sent him home with
antibiotics but then he kept getting
worse and so a week later doesn't kill
parasites a week later he returned to
the hospital and then that's when he
went to the neurology department and
they did blood tests
and that's when they determined that his
immune system was attacking his spine
and so that's what led to the loss of
the control of his legs and so he was
put on a six-month course of steroids to
counter that but they still didn't know
what was causing oh my god so that's
when the buff legs nobody couldn't feel
this though it's like I'm getting so
buff but I feel like [ __ ] man so then
they finally found out that a parasitic
worm had crawled up his penis and laid
eggs inside his body and multiplied
because of the parasitic worms were
moving through the blood areas of his
body like the liver and his bowels they
started finding out that they had eggs
so they replicated in his body so then
he was prescribed medication to kill the
eggs and that did kill the infection but
then he was left basically debilitated
because they told him that there was a
30% chance that he could make a full
recovery
ten years from now oh my god of going
swimming yeah what about swimming stop
swimming you guys yeah he he ended up
saying that he spent three months in a
wheelchair in a hospital and then four
months on crutches and so he was saying
that early in his recovery sometime in
January he had like a really terrible
acne outbreak that went all down the
back up like his back and his arms and
so he couldn't sleep for a month because
lying on his back would was very hurtful
and he couldn't even shower like
sleeping on bubble wrap his pimples
popping lift her right
he couldn't be under running water
either so he only could shower his front
watch one side of his body yeah tired
back and so he ended up losing the
feeling of his legs um like I said look
and okay and so and then also around
that same time he couldn't use the
toilet normally either so she had music
laughter oh and he was just saying like
he was so weak that his girlfriend
couldn't even hug him because it was too
painful and she left them no that's the
end of the story waiting for the
girlfriend thing that you said that we
need to find almost make you so has it
cuz the catheter where is it going yeah
they put in this big that's repose
piccolo know more about this man tell me
he got better
no there's nothing else who gave us this
story you know [ __ ] that guy wonder if
that parasite is common or if it's like
one of those like it's not usual so like
what happens after this right so you go
and is there science I'd say if you go
in this lake you might catch a parasite
that will slide into your penis and you
won't be able to walk again
that makes me never wanna ever so much I
so I mean lakes when I was younger but I
still have it in my adulthood and I
always think of [ __ ] like this because
in Stillwater is where you catch it
something like know it bad neighbor's
pool that's still water not doing it
well [ __ ] I'm doing it good for you man
play it safe the chlorine water 32 I
mean at the best vacation oh that turned
into a nightmare dream holiday but Mike
months later could you imagine that you
like just have no idea what the hell's
going on where was he view in Africa
what is the name of this lake so we
cannot everybody not to go Southeast
Africa we can't pull this Lake Lake
Malawi Malawi Lake they should put
chlorine in that Lake that's pretty
famously very crude what if you get one
of those stickers that hides girls
nipples we're not wearing bron.steve put
it on yeah pasty upon the tip of the
dick you just seal the hole holes in
your my hole well Nikki you buy three
sicker are you sticking us lost roles
but he didn't even feel it you like your
turn it will hold like Hines only like
this baby let's be real like where your
pee comes I was like only like this big
right probably
okay so it went in there and he didn't
even know well it was probably
microscopic right so so it doesn't
matter so you got a little like cut yeah
it could go through your eye and go
through anything don't go in like mm I
wonder what like this parasite lives in
normally like in the lake or just in the
animals or cuz they gotta have a host to
survive it's just the penis do all the
problem
oh so if people are eating the fish to
do you fish you know what they fish have
parasites but you cook them and it's
usually in the gut not in the muscle
okay good to know
Thank You teacher and no matter what now
he's the parasite dick guy that's double
sucks I mean but also the buff like back
temple dude hey but she ya the vacation
of a lifetime can you imagine if you had
a shitty vacation and he comes back in
it's even shittier he's like I had to
sleep on bubble wrap
and when I heard the bubble wrap hopin
sometimes it was Bubba write concisely
pit on his back he's also missing
highbrow steer so this is after the
parasite on before that was the vacation
of his lifetime we tried to end it on a
happy note tattoo it's terrible that the
world's reacted to this guy has a lot of
bad decisions just what kind of
butterfly it's like but if I were got
made out of guns I'd feel bad in the
white tattoo revolvers that make a
butterfly logo to the expendables he's
from London
I feel so bad for this dude pray for
this guy I feel bad for his taste
[Music]